[Music]
but we begin this show with what could
be a pivotal few days over the crisis in
ukraine after the latest shelling in the
eastern part of the country our harley
williams was the only network reporter
to visit a kindergarten allegedly hit by
russian-backed forces the violence comes
as the u.s and nato countries say russia
could be on the brink of invading
ukraine at any moment holly is now back
in keep safely back in kiev ukraine's
capital holly good morning
good morning there's been an escalation
in violence in eastern ukraine where
government forces have been fighting a
war against russian-backed separatists
since 2014. both sides are blaming each
other but this comes as the u.s claims
russia may have already begun a
so-called false flag operation
we flew with ukraine's military to the
country's far east under 10 miles from
the russian border to the village of
stanitza luhanska where ukraine says
russian-backed separatists fired heavy
artillery into civilian areas yesterday
including this school ironically named
fairytale kindergarten a place of
innocence now shattered
children would have had a lesson in the
room that was hit just minutes later
according to yulia samenco who works at
the school
when you look at the damage here it must
have been terrifying for the children
that were inside this building
we were told none of the students were
hurt but ukraine says three adults were
injured
ukrainian soldiers showed us where they
said another artillery shell hit in the
playground there were no children here
at the time yeah they all were inside
building on the second floor
in eastern ukraine government forces
have been fighting russian-backed
separatists for nearly eight years
a bloody conflict that's cost over
fourteen thousand lives according to
ukraine
but now with nearly 160 000 russian
troops estimated to be massed along
ukraine's border there are fears russia
could stage or provoke a violent
incident as a pretext for invasion a
scenario the u.s claims may already have
started we have reason to believe that
they are
engaged in a false flag operation to
have an excuse to go in
some believe russia's president vladimir
putin is playing a high-stakes game of
cold war style brinkmanship using the
threat of invasion trying to extract
concessions from the u.s and its allies
if that's true it's a dangerous game
civilians could pay with their lives
president putin will oversee military
exercises tomorrow by his country's
nuclear forces including the launching
of ballistic and cruise missiles russia
says that shouldn't worry anyone vlad
as the world collectively holds their
breath holly williams in ukraine for us
thank you very much